Узбережжя Балтійського моря. Мальовниче містечко Засніц на острові Рюген.
Тут мало що відбувається - хіба що туристи приїжджають.
Що ми зробили, що американським сенаторам спало на думку нам погрожувати?
Цілком несподівано Засніц опинився у фокусі міжнародної економічної політики,
ставши актором у давньому конфлікті.
Мер отримав пошту з Вашингтона. Жодних дружніх вітань, лист з погрозами.
Мовляв, проти поромного порту будуть запроваджені санкції, які фінансово його знищать
Крім того, варто очікувати серйозних правових наслідків.
У листі висловлюються погрози з метою не дати завершити "Північний потік-2".
Це головна причина. Портове підприємство нашого містечка взяли під приціл,
оскільки там була виробнича база, яка займалась обшивкою труб.
Тепер ми маємо утриматися від розміщення та оснащення кораблів.
Для мене це вже надмірне зухвальство.
Труби для останньої ділянки газогону "Північний потік-2"
між Росією та Німеччиною лежать в порту Мукран.
Будівництво трубопроводу давно мало б завершитися.
Але наприкінці 2019 року роботи припинили.
Рішення про систему підводних газопроводів свого часу ухвалили ще
колишній канцлер Німеччини Ґергард Шредер та президент Росії Володимир Путін.
Перша нитка газогону вже експлуатується з 2011 року і пролягає
від російського портового міста Виборг до Любміна поблизу Грайфсвальда.
Другій нитці не вистачає лише160 кілометрів перед самим узбережжям.
Трубопровід дратує американців. Вони вважають, що Європа стає
надто залежною від російського газу.
А отже і від доброї волі Путіна.
Європа та Німеччина не повинні миритися з тим, що нам диктують ззовні,
як працювати, яку енергополітику проводити, які проєкти впроваджувати тут, у Засніці.
Перші поставки газу з тодішнього Радянського Союзу
надійшли до Західної Німеччини ще у 1973 році.
У розпал нафтової кризи.
Вже тоді США реагували роздратовано.
Однак байдуже, з комуністичним режимом чи пізніше з Путіним -
газовий бізнес між Німеччиною та Росією постійно розширювався -
попри часто великі політичні розбіжності.
Санкції завжди вступають у гру, коли політичні інтереси
мають підсилюватись економічним тиском - як у Засніці.
Порт як пункт забезпечення газопроводу створює робочі місця та приносить прибуток регіону.
Однак тепер місцеві підприємства розгублені.
Усім компаніям, які беруть участь у проєкті, загрожують ці екстериторіальні санкції.
Ми як Торгова палата стикаємося з великими труднощами,
коли геополітичних цілей досягають за допомогою економічної політики та економічних заходів.
Звичайно, це впливає і на наші малі підприємства, особливо у прибережній зоні
ми маємо справу з кораблями, які заходять до нас з усього світу.
Звісно, хочеться вести міжнародну торгівлю та бізнес із усіма країнами світу.
Політика відкритої торгівлі надзвичайно важлива, особливо для компаній на узбережжі.
Загалом від санкцій можуть постраждати 350 компаній.
Від маленького інженерного офісу до великого підприємства з оснащення суден.
І тому так важливо, щоб у нас були торгові контракти по всьому світу.
Адже те, що зараз сталося, є дивовижним. Знову діє право сильного у світі.
У Засніці місцеві жителі просто хочуть знову мати спокій.
Якщо США досягнуть успіху в своїй тактиці,
у майбутньому міжнародним компаніям доведеться шукати інший порт.